hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in part one of
the spoke zarathustra there's a short
section called of war and warriors Keg
and craig volca the people who live on
and desire and you could say have their
meaning in war and battle in conflict
and Nietzsche is often interpreted as
somebody who glorifies conflict as you
might say highest good in this case it's
not quite so simple as that he is saying
that that Warriors are great but they're
sort of second best and if they can't be
this then at least they can be warriors
and that's because war and the kind of
disposition or a mindset or a
comportment that it it encompasses and
brings about is itself good but it's not
as good as the highest good you could
say at the very end of that section he
tells them you should let me commend to
you your highest idea and it is man is
something that should be overcome now
are you overcoming yourself in war to a
certain extent yes but not entirely and
so we're going to see that the clues to
the
in what what Nietzsche has to say at the
very beginning he says be a warrior if
certain conditions hold if you aren't
great enough to expunge hatred and envy
from your heart if you're not great
enough to not know hatred and envy then
at least don't be ashamed to them
embrace them hatred and envy the the
Envy that wants you to to be above
somebody else if you have that
disposition okay go with it don't try to
hide it don't just shove it down don't
be a nice boy or a nice girl and pretend
like you don't have these desires and
drives that's if you do have these
desires and drives obviously it's better
for Nietzsche if you don't he also goes
on and he says if you can't be a saint
of knowledge then be it's warriors
so warriors are in a certain sense
subordinate they're still high but
they're not the highest now how should
the warrior who Nietzsche says he loves
very much how should the warrior live
Nietzsche tells him that you should seek
out enemies you should seek your enemy
should wager war a war for your opinions
if your opinion is defeated your honesty
should still cry triumph over that you
can take the light in the conflict and
have a certain nobility of character
that allows you to say at least I
struggled at least I tried at least I
stepped into the ring you should hate
your enemy Nietzsche says but you
shouldn't despise your enemy if you're
only fighting against those who you
despise those who you look down upon
what's the point in that you should
actually seek out enemies who are up to
you who could defeat you don't just go
for the easy conflicts don't be the sort
of person who takes on just the sure
thing that's not being a warrior
according to Nietzsche so he tells us a
little bit later you may have enemies
who you hate not an
despise you must be proud of your enemy
then the success of your enemy shall be
your success too even when the enemy is
defeating you you can at least say huh
well fought good show so it's not just
about you triumphing or you succeeding
are you shoving everybody else's face in
the dust there's a recognition that's
required from the enemy for the warrior
according to Nietzsche he also has a
brief passage here about soldiers he
says I see many soldiers if only I could
see so many warriors so clearly there's
a distinction between soldiers and
warriors he says what they wear is
called uniform may what they conceal
with it not be uniform to the soldier is
somebody who is like everybody else in
some respect they dress like everybody
else they obey orders like everybody
else they are not a warrior as such
there has to be individuality in order
to be a warrior so that tells you a lot
about what the warrior is is like and
should do there's another key thing here
that again shows you that the warrior is
not at the apex of Nietzsche's hierarchy
the warrior he says should let nobility
show itself in obeying he says you know
rebelling that shows nobility of slave
but let your nobility show itself in
obeying let even your commanding be
obeying so even when you're in charge
you should be obeying something else not
just making it up as you go along
not just deciding for yourself not just
you know filling your pockets with loot
you should be obedient to something else
here Nietzsche says that what should
really be driving the warrior is thou
shalt not I will and if you look back a
little bit earlier in part one you see
that the lion who is the most of
warriors in some respect the lion
doesn't do that the lion and the three
transformations of
very beginning of this part the lion
says I'm not going to go along with your
thou shalt I'm gonna say no to this so
the lion in some respects transcends
what Nietzsche here is calling the
warrior in any case the warrior finds
his or her purpose in following the thou
shalt in obedience in subjecting
themselves and doing so to others as
well the other thing that we have to say
about this passage is that there's some
reversals of valuation here that give
rise to the conception that needs to
does in pack view war and conflict as
good things he tells us that the warrior
should he says I don't exhort exhort you
to work but to battle I don't exhort you
to peace but to victory may your work be
a battle mayor peace be a victory and
then he says that you should love peace
as a means to new wars so there's a
reversal of value here very often we
still while we can we engage in war not
because we love war itself but because
it allows us to enjoy peace you might
think of st. Augustine's famous
discussion in City of God book 19
precisely about this and discussions in
Cicero - about this and on Duty's
nietzsche saying no that's wrong
peace you have a peace hopefully a short
one so you can engage in a new war a new
conflict what else he tells us that the
good war Hallows every quest to say that
it Hallows it means that it makes it
holy it endowed it with value as opposed
to you know waiting around until you've
got a good caused and then going to war
sort of like the person who's always
like hey hey you're gonna you're gonna
cross the line man so then I can fight
you you just cross the line you know
doesn't start the fight and then you'll
have a good cause this is again a
reversal of valuation it goes against
what we would normally say is good and
then Nietzsche has a third thing he says
war and courage have done more great
things than here it's translated as
charity a little bit closer translation
it would be love of
neighbor knocks the liebe you know the
love of one who is closest to you war
and and courage have created more war
and courage have protected more so you
know that again a reversal compared to
the culture of his time and you can see
that Nietzsche is saying that that war
is a good thing and warriors are good
people they're just not the absolute
best and they have to find the right
framework within which they can live
this out
you